well when I started playing chess I was
quite young that was 12 and that was
considered old by the way for chess
players I think it's considered older
today than it was even in those days so
12 was a late start and unfortunately
between school and other activities and
life it was really really really hard
for me to study chess and I needed you
know something to get through the
opening so I just didn't lose and stuff
like that and it wasn't that I was lazy
I was just that I didn't have enough
time to study and I worked very hard at
the board and my favorite opening move
with the English c4 okay so this was it
this was the cat's meow c4 and I would
play this move as a neo religion but the
advantages of this move c4 is that we
control two squares of chessboard B Phi
and d5 but the disadvantages is that we
look at our Bishop on f1 we go hey man
if our if our intention had been to
develop the bishop on this diagonal
well you sure put the kibosh by putting
the pawn on c4 you're putting the bishop
you've got the pawn in the way of the
bishop the most popular and I think
that's true today as well the most
popular ways of meeting the English was
with c5 the symmetrical in English and E
5 and I think these two moves still are
the over right are the most popular this
move e5 kind of reverse Sicilian if you
will as the most popular way of meeting
the English of course you could play a
Slav defense with c6 and d5 or Queens
gambit idea with a 6 and d5 but
virtually all my opponents
would play e5 I mean this was like
accepted tabia position and I would play
g3 okay so I knew the features of the
Battle of the battlefield I knew that
the best diagonals for licious were the
long diagonals so I reason let's just
start them and put them there right away
g3 okay and I would want to put my
bishop on g2 and notice and then I would
want to put my knight on c3 and notice
the harmony of this pawn this Knight
this Bishop all controlling the d5
square like yes and today as in those
days Knight f6 Bishop g2 d5 was
conviction disposition this opening was
considered a a good choice for black but
a lot of people didn't like playing an
open Sicilian literally a tempo behind
which is what black is doing and after
Knight c3 again this was a very popular
defense but it wasn't to everybody's
taste as black today you find for
example I think it was in Zurich a
tournament that just happened very
recently that Magnus Carlsen was white
lavona Rhone ian was black and Levon
Aronian had a good game with black and
those days that I was playing chess it
was far far more common by maybe a
factor five that my opponents would play
knight c6 I would play Bishop g2 my
opponents would play g6 Knight c3 Bishop
g7 okay so now it's sort of like you
know we're just kind of getting the feel
for one another and in a sense black is
kind of copying me he's being shadowing
is Bishop hooding is Bishop on the lung
agonal he's making a fortress for his
King he's intending to go castling that
way I'm intending to go castling that
way and one of the things is the center
is still amorphous white hasn't made any
clear stand in the center I I could for
example play III followed by putting my
night on e - I could play d3 new
variation and Knight f3 so I put that
kind of setup I could even go forward
the BOD Vinik triangle and play E for
variation and then put my night on e -
and my pawn on d3 so in other words the
center is very fluid I can do a lot of
things so keeping that in mind my
favorite move here was the move rook b1
now this was a this is the strategic
ideas class alright so how many of you
would have played rook e1 in this
position it doesn't really is not like
the first thing that comes to mind right
okay so here's my logic behind the move
rook b1 first of all it kind of and I
like this - it flies in the face of
conventional wisdom the conventional
wisdom is you develop your pawns in the
center you develop your Knights in the
center you develop your bishops in the
center you castle then you move your
queen to a decent square and then you
think of a plan
okay that was how you do it in the
opening I like the move rook b1 very
much oops where am I I did something
wrong
rook b1 tuck
yeah because it was sort of like I went
backwards it's like I have a plan and
then the rest of the development that I
have in mind has got to fit the plan
that I'm going to do I play the move
rook b1 before I develop my minor pieces
or castling my King so that I could play
b4 and I could have an attack on the
Queen side and in my mind's eye what I
was trying to do was go b4 b5 and once I
played to move b5 I attack this Knight
force it to move either into the center
or to take a retreat square and once I
get rid of this night I improve the
vision of my bishop right most of my
opponents but not all but most of my
opponent's played a5 to slow down my ID
I didn't care i played a3 most of my
opponents blade d6 wonderful b4 trade
trade now we'll pause here for a second
and say which rook is better in other
words my rook on b1 doesn't control any
of black squares yet but blacks rook on
a 8 controls four of my square so in
other words heaven I just simply
improved my opponent's rook more than I
approved my rook and the proper answer
is absolutely yes blacks rook has been
improved enormous ly so a lot of the
black players were happy to the point
where they actually felt that they had
somehow gone beyond equality and that
they stood better and it's a it's a it's
reasonable to make such an argument
because this rook is better than this
rook however I had a deeper idea
strategic idea behind this whole play
and that was was that when I play my
move b5
my future idea is going to be involving
continual advances of c5 and b6 and my
rook on B file might yet prove its
worthiness greater than this rook on the
a file because if you look on the a file
all the business squares a1 a2 a3 are
protected so the rook is not at this
moment threatening to invade let's see
my opponents I had a game with I had
many many games with grandmaster Walter
brown where Walter often played f5 I had
other games with other grandmasters
Archer Yusupov Arthur busy wire and many
others that was Knight f6 and I've had
other players playing Knight g8 to e7
against me ok of the choices that I've
just offered I give me some feedback
Julian what what move in this position
would you make for Black Knight ge7 ok
very very nice choice so after Knight
ge7 I desperately want to play b5 but
after the move b5 I notice that the
knight is going to come jumping to d4 I
could chase the night backwards but then
the knight might go to e6 and possibly
to c5
I notice that with your knight on e7
that you've actually just taken away
your your retreat square so I'll play
III first exactly now the whole
strategic idea of this variation of the
English is predicated on this Bishop
really being good being awesome
so what I want to do is I want to play
b5 move this night away now because you
forced me to play e3 I leave my knight
here
my room my pawn here I'll castle I'll
tuck my king away and I'll be very
pleased about this long diagonal and
this was terrific i I just won a ton of
games a lot most of my games I would say
a majority of my games are not in the
databases because I started and I played
in all of these open tournaments and in
those days nobody a bulletin would be
very rare I played in the US Open my
games first of all wouldn't make it to
the bulletin and if there was such a
thing as a bulletin in the US Open it
would only have a small small selection
of game and I would play in like the st.
Louis chess club weekend Swiss ah's and
Congress events and latter tournaments
and so none of my all these games got
involved into the databases that I
probably about 4000 tournament games and
I think in the database of about 1900
games in the chess base okay and I want
a ton of games from this and I really
like this to the story of Mike Sahadi
Mike Shehadeh as you know as the father
of Jennifer and Gregg jihad II and there
was a guy a grandmaster from the Soviet
Union and his name was Anatoly Lane and
anatoly had stayed with the shahad Iza
mike's invitation and he had complained
to Mike about me
yeah Anatoly had said what is it about
this guy Sarah won he plays rugby 1 B 4
B 5 he beats everybody and they call him
genius it is really great like V 1 B 4 B
5 is a genius it's arable so now Jillian
you have to support you have to follow
up after your 97 III what would you like
to do for black pardon me Castle it's
correct
I will go b5
9 b8 night ii night GE 2
Knight d7 and excellent move catalyst
and if you notice you're discovering for
yourself that the strange thing is this
pawn on b7 is a little bit awkward to
defend you're starting to think maybe if
you play Knight c5 it's clear that
you're just encouraging me to play d4
and take over the center with the tempo
if you play Knight b6 you're encouraging
me to play moves like Queen b3 Bishop a
3 C 4 C 5 is something I want to do
anyway and if you play a move C 7 C 6
well then after takes on c6 takes on c6
guess what I have an open B file as well
for my rook and maybe some edge in the
position we're going to go back a moment
back back back to this position and
we're going to play like Walter Shawn
Brown did and we're going to play f5
yeah f5 I would play d2 d3 now exactly
this moment you do have the opportunity
to play E for but I will play Knight to
d5 and then captures and I'll recapture
with the Queen and maybe that pawn
structure isn't so good for you as black
Walter Brown usually played Knight f6
against me I play b5 he played 97 I play
Knight f3 he play castles I played
castles and I think this was a position
so now the kind again the center isn't
the
the center can suddenly shift at any
moment black might play e4 white might
play e4 d for the center can break and
it's very clear that if you just don't
do anything my intention is to play
Queen b3 c5 oftentimes comes with a
check
Bishop a3 and oftentimes b6 so I'm
getting this space on the Queen side and
I'm trying always to use the harmony of
this diagonal a lot of my opponents
decided that the best their best chance
late in a counter-attack on the King
side and they would play h7 h6 here okay
and then my idea was to play c4 c5 okay
so here what I'm trying to do is I'm
trying to create a target in my
opponent's camp the target may be the d6
pawn sometimes I want to play the move
b6 mostly I want to play Queen Shack
move your king take this pawn take this
pawn play Bishop a3 92 94 you see all of
that I'm trying to cause problems on the
Queen side and in the center usually in
conjunction with the move beasts six I
was happy to accept this trade of pawns
because firstly I've doubled my
opponent's pawn secondly I don't lose a
piece this is very important do not lose
pieces this is not good Queen d4 which
is a nasty attack against the knight on
e5 and the knight on c3 is met by Queen
b3 check and I can either retreat my
knight against your queen or protect my
knight so I'm not losing a piece neither
if you move your night away
from h7 let's say if you move your night
to h7 I still have this move Queen B 3
check and I can avoid the loss of a
night so here most of my opponents
played King h8 ok new maintain line yeah
and I would play Queen B 3 uh and a lot
of a lot of my games uh this almost was
like at abia I I think I must have had
this position three or four times
against Walter brown and in all of these
open tournaments that we competed
against one another
normally he got the best of me he Walter
was a kind of a nemesis of mine I've had
so many nemesis I don't even know where
to start that there was a few things
that I just wanted to point out about
this whole strategy that I I'm sure I
didn't develop it I certainly advanced
it but I'm sure others played it before
me was this idea that sometimes you can
initiate a flank attack early without
going through this process of bringing
all your pieces out and castling and I
was going to say that I've actually you
could do it in reverse
- I've seen this by black yeah I know
what you're going to say but correct
yeah exactly look you did it once ok so
II for c5 this is based upon the idea of
white playing not an open Sicilian
rather a closed Sicilian
and we get a standard position and Lubow
amongst many others me soft as well play
rook b8 and literally have the reversal
of what I was showing you with white
first initiating a queen side attack
getting a pawn roller and only then
later saying hey man what am I going to
do about my development on the Kings
side am I going to develop my knight to
e7 or to f6 put my pawn on d6
and one of the reasons why I really like
to do this is white because it just
avoided a whole lot of theory who wants
to spend you know 60 hours learning a
group held or a hundred hours lugar near
Kings India and there I had 200 hours
learning the Queens gambit declined so
the English was like an opening that I
really liked so let me just go back to
the start for a second and see for what
happens if my opponent would play c5
okay
new variation I would play a knight c3
and I remember this game I played with
Sammy Reshevsky from Lone Pine
California I thought it was a pretty
funny game I was white okay so this is
what they all call the symmetrical
English and I think most grandmasters
prefer Knight f3 at this exact moment
and what I preferred was to play a3 with
a similar idea as to what I was doing
against 'if I've which is I wanted to
play rook B 1 and B 4 well I my own it
was Sammy Reshevsky and he was a
stubborn old guy and he played a 6
against me I went cook b1 and he went
rook b8
and I went b4 and he took my pond and he
went b5 and sort of like anything you
can do I can do better kind of the only
like a dead man
so his idea of course is that if I take
his pond he takes my pond it's a very
symmetrical position and blacks chances
for equality are simply excellent but
this was also a pet variation of mine
and I reasoned as follows why on earth
should I trade this pawn on a6
for this excellent pawn on c4 right I
mean my pawn on c4 controls two of his
squares his pawn simply acts as a
defender I played the move c5 okay so
I'm keeping my pawn structure intact and
in my mind's eye if I'm able if you let
me I will play Knight f3 and d4 or
perhaps III d4 Knight on GE 2 and I'll
have a superior structure so Sammy
played a 5 attacking my pawn now I
didn't like the idea that if I capture
you would play b4 and play Queen takes a
5 I played Bishop a 3 he took I took he
took I took now
again to my way of thinking I'm thinking
I'm really really close to just winning
the game if I can play the move d4
Knight f3 castles Queen b3 that's a win
I just win this pawn so he has to do
something really really good I'm hoping
for the move Queen a5 and against the
move Queen a 5 let me just put that on
the board this is this was a I have won
many games that went Queen a5 Queen b3
Queen a1 check and here I was very proud
of my move Knight d1 one of these days I
have to check these old ideas with a
computer you know like I just got a
cherry is what the modern computers
might think of like and I I rationalized
that ok again my idea is to play Knight
f3 castles the Queen's no good one day
I'm just simply threatening to rip this
pawn and it's very very hard for black
to develop it mean
put your Bishop on a6 wonderful it
doesn't any problem put your Bishop on
b7 you're walking into a pin and black
has issues
yeah so here I was you know on the verge
of like chalking up another one you know
like that I have won so many queen a
queen bee three games and Reshevsky he
was notorious for really thinking like
an hour and then getting into time
trouble and he was also a blitz very
very dangerous when he's in time trouble
it seemed to me like he improved his
position he'd go into time trouble in a
messy game you get into time trouble he
ended up in a blitz with his opponent
and he'd outplay his opponent so here
reshef he went into a long thing he had
fallen into my pet
trap and can you guess what what
Sammy plate is black in this position
after an hour's think by the way again
yeah like it's amazing you have any
played and he played a Bishop takes c3
yeah he played Bishop takes c3 and at
the at the time it wasn't that it was so
radical I mean I played move like Bishop
takes c6 and giving up my bishop for a
knight but it was really kind of
explosive in the sense that basically
any other move than Bishop takes c3 just
lands black in a bad position like it's
really remarkable that black is that
close to real real danger and that if
white is able to play deform Queen b3 he
can resign and after Bishop takes c3 it
was just this thought that you know the
classical grandmasters and you know
people who taught me or offered advice
would say this Bishop is great yeah I
mean you know like they'd almost slap
you on the hand how dare you consider
giving up such a bishop but in this
particular case after Bishop takes c3 D
takes c3 Queen c7 I play Queen d4 Knight
f6 Knight f3 castles castles Bishop d7
exclamation mark reshef ski was just in
time to equalize if you don't play this
move if we go back for a second what is
White's threat White's threat really is
simply to play rook F 1 to be 1 followed
by c3 c4 and thanks to the rook on the
back being pinned that's really strong
an if black plays for some thing like
Bishop a
six there is the move Queen e5 and if we
can relate to a moment for a Catalan
after Bishop a six Queen e5 I just want
to put these moves on the board not that
these are great moves for either side
but just to this idea that this Bishop
once again the whole strategic class you
know the vision on this diagonal the
knight on e5 is very nice rook and slide
over to a1 this pawn on b5 is a certain
weakness and I think that our game if I
recall it when Bishop beauty seven I
went I think I went rook takes b5 this
was probably a poor move by me and we
win something like this
and we later drew an ending yet but
again it was just this idea that of
feein shadowing early developing a flank
attack before just going with the
classical development that made a big
impact in my chest career probably I won
hundreds and hundreds of rating points
playing this English against my
opponents but more than that it was an
idea of avoiding a lot of theory having
this whole development if you will
flowing out of this long diagonal like
all of my play was based on keeping that
long diagonal open and occupying d5
squares then I and this greatest
tournament of all time and it's just
been played at Zurich it's really really
cool these yes so so here's oh man if I
can call him that forgive me Boris
Gelfand playing you know his d4 opening
and there's hyper active aggressive
Hikaru Nakamura is Black Knight f6 and
there's very solid Boris Knight f3 and
then there's he six and it's like what
the heck is that c4 and G by Nakamura
horribly he got crushed by boy it was a
model it was a yeah it was a rapid game
but it was a model model game of how to
really punish somebody who's advanced on
a flank so I was never really attracted
to these flank ideas either from the
white side or the black side of a king
side
I thought that was taking too many
liberties but I always liked the
queenside be fours and be fives for both
players I just thought that you know you
don't want to do that to your King when
you do something early like a flank
attack and you're not controlling the
center then by classical definitions
you're giving up at a chance for an
advantage right that by not paying
enough attention to the center you've
given your opponent a chance to equalize
and maybe equalizes more than equalize
you know like go ahead of you
so it has that risk or drawback now on
the other hand just because you play the
most classical perfect opening doesn't
give you a definitive advantage
Oh